foreign
the car is the largest thing and I'm a
car person I like cars I'm a anything
with a loud Muffler I'm a good redneck
and so
um you know I I I get it
um but cars go down in value they're the
largest purchase
that we as consumers make that goes down
in value and consequently the the
arithmetic tells us
that
uh the car payment and today the average
car payment America is over 700 dollars
the car payment is more of a detriment
to your wealth your ability to become
wealthy then just about anything else
that's exactly right and as you point
out all the time you're putting all that
time and effort you just think about the
amount of time you spend at work how
much of a percentage of your overall
expenses that vehicle is and then remind
yourself it's depreciating in value and
you're going to be upside down in it
before you know it and that's what I
mean Georgia we George and I uh
co-hosted the show a week a circle and
he showed me this Tick Tock video we
played for the audience and people
admitting with Glee Dave that they had a
1200 car payment uh one couple said we
have twenty four hundred dollars in car
payments and they were saying it with a
smile on their face like hey it's just
what you're supposed to do and it's
mind-numbing the messaging that goes
into this that you've got to have a
brand new car or a newer car and people
are overspending to your point they
cannot afford it you know and and it
really let me just tell you what it is
okay
it's prestige exactly right status
you're right because look at my car and
everything else you say about it is is a
justification and a lie completely but
at the end of the day it's Prestige
because a 32 000 van will haul four kids
and so will a ten thousand dollar van
all four kids safely we're not putting
their little lives in Jeopardy right
that's a bunch of crap that's right and
it's not you know well I want something
reliable and all those used cars are
reliable you know what your new car is a
year after you got it it's used yes and
you know it must be about to break down
you must be about to die right now and
by the way kids destroy a new car as
quickly as they do a used car they don't
care they're going to throw their little
Mott's applesauce containers and their
Cheetos and goldfish everywhere have you
seen a local car you must have been
inside Rachel I haven't but I know she's
got three kids so welcome she's got
three kids and she's never kept a clean
car in her whole life oh boy but it's
just like uh man she it looks like a
trash hole and it's like but it's got
It's got the it's a little bit goldfish
are ground into the carpet you know it's
like oh my God but yeah the the and that
it doesn't matter what you pay for
that's what you're gonna have that's why
boy why buy a brand new van when the
kids are gonna destroy it well it's okay
if you've got two million dollars if you
want to go buy a brand new van yeah but
that doesn't happen but but we're
talking about somebody making 75 000
somebody making 50 000 the 26 000 car
thirty two thousand dollar car oh man
this is um you know and all it is is you
get car fever which you know you which
means your your brain quits working
right and you start you go oh we have to
have something reliable we have to have
something safe and we haven't we have
babies we have to have room for them all
we can't put them in this whole thing
and well that's true that old thing may
need to be changed out for a different
old thing but true
um
but listen you're just you're
mathematically saying with that purchase
I intend to stay in the middle class yes
that's what that is it's a death
sentence yeah to your math yeah you
settle for it well I'm going to settle
for the life I have to live just so that
I can feel good about myself when I pull
up to soccer practice and my car looks
like everybody else's or maybe a bit
nicer yeah you really nailed it on the
whole status symbol thing well it's even
worse than soccer practice it's the
stoplight oh right at least you know the
people at soccer practice the people at
the stoplight you'll never meet them and
the amount of money you lost while you
were sitting there at the stoplight to
impress someone you will never meet is
astronomical so true I had a young guy
call on the show one time and talk about
how he was in sales and he needed the
really nice car because it went into his
entire credibility and I said let me
tell you something you realize there's
parking spaces in the back of the lot or
around the corner they don't care what
you're driving you're not driving into
the lobby of their building park around
the back
look sharp use an iron you're gonna be
okay you're gonna brush your teeth take
a bath you don't need a super nice car
to close a deal yeah if you do then you
got the wrong deal yeah it's it's a
problem I you know I've I've done sales
most of my life in one kind or another
and I don't recall ever making or losing
a sale based on what I was driving it's
true when I said when I first moved to
Nashville years ago and I was in sales I
was driving a Ford Taurus Dave that had
no air conditioning and the the carpet
or whatever you'd call the fabric on the
roof headliner hey thank you Dave I just
said carpet the car it probably did have
carpet
if there's a Target
but the top of the thing one day David
started drooping yeah and and Stacy and
I were newly married we've been married
two years and I literally had a staple
gun that I bought recently for household
Duty and I fell in love with the staple
gun Jeremy Breeland one of our leaders
here saw this I got out of the car one
day it was irritating me was it coming
down I'm a short guy and I got home and
I went and grabbed my staple gun in the
garage I went and went three Staples it
was fantastic until I gave it away to a
a 16 year old girl in our church that
needed a car but I drove it for three
more years with Staples in the headline
I've done that too get over it nobody
cared it was a great story actually yeah
and you need those stories to be able to
tell your kids someday yeah